I could ask you the dog and you could
say well I don't feel like dancing I
mean I could say well maybe some other
time or I could just not violin or
caption life we're talking about Robin
and he's practically a stranger the
thing is I just know this is it I know
you are you feeling - good I got what
was going on respirator people paralyzed
by polio GERD last long can't move
anything from the neck down can't even
breathe yourself
louder laughter like this yes you sir I
love you and I want Jonathan to know you
yes yes I can there must be something I
can do
get me out of it probably can't leave
the hospital no one with your husband's
disability exists Idaho has anyone ever
tried robbing robbing the right guy much
better
five pounces we'll never make it
you're on now in court have you I've had
an idea a wheelchair that does his
breathing for him are you sure it's safe
yeah it works a car
Alan Jeremy if I found Tammy bastard why
do you keep your disabled people in
prison no one believes is possible to
live as you do well we should open the
gate and set them free
bloody viral up in a well for wouldn't
that be an adventure when I first became
paralyzed I wanted to die my wife told
me I had to live
yeah um girl your life is my life I
don't want to just survive I want and
truly live
[Music]
I think he should be in hospital
no you're quite right no
[Music]
you